[Music]
hello normally when you think of words
they fit into a language bonjour but
there's a relatively new class of words
that don't quite follow the rules and
it's called wasago
john kelly is a language writer i spend
a lot of my time writing about word
origins he's a linguistics expert and he
knows just about everything about the
phenomenon called wasellego
wasse ego literally means japan made
english it is a language process that
takes foreign words usually english
words and transmogrifies them into
something wholly new and novel for
japanese purposes
we see this with a word like karaoke
everybody knows and everybody loves
karaoke but it joins the japanese kara
which means empty and okay which is a
japanese rendering of orchestra so a
karaoke is an empty orchestra the most
popular example is the word pokemon the
creator of pokemon took two english
words pocket and monster he smashed them
together and got pokemon or take cosplay
a word that describes people dressing up
as fictional characters cosplay joins
costume and play and there's anime anime
is a fairly straightforward rendering of
the english animation quasi hugo is
important because language is always
changing and reinventing itself what new
words will pop up in the future only
time will tell
[Music]
you